it is time for a national conversation a
national conversation about national
conversations this will be no ordinary
sort of conversation because between you
and me I am starting to think that
lefties who keep demanding national
conversations don't actually want to
have conversations at all I don't know
why I think that we will discuss we will
converse then why the total hysteria
over illegal immigration is actually a
healthy sign for our culture not just in
America but across Western civilization
we will look at examples even back in
the old country then in some other good
news for the culture Chris Pratt
preaches the gospel at the MTV Movie
Awards and finally on this day in
history the US executed Soviet spies
Julius and Ethel Rosenberg but the left
just don't want to admit it I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
a lot of conversations to get to today I
think I spent about a solid 45 minutes
just doing Twitter yesterday and then
there are all these sort of fake news
articles that came out of it we will
discuss why lefties are so angry on
these these conversations on Twitter
before we get to that I got to make a
little money honey we got to talk about
a wonderful piece of software which is
software advice software advice is so
important when you're dealing with a
real head-scratcher having your go-to
person to call is a no-brainer that is
where software advice comes in so I know
this also because I've worked at small
businesses of started businesses when it
comes to picking the right software for
your business software advice has done
all the research for you so you start a
business and you need software to get
started but you don't know what will is
this client better than this client is
this software better than this how do
you do it how will this integrate what
will it do blah blah blah don't waste
your time don't waste your money you
know you've got to get a business off
the ground do it the right way do it
more effectively and do it with a
software advice which is absolutely free
just go to software advice.com slash
Knolls kayano wles answer a few short
questions about your business you will
be connected with an advisor to discuss
the best software options for your needs
talking to an advisor takes just 10
minutes or less and you know this I'm a
millennial so I don't do anything that
takes more than 10 minutes whether
you're a medical professional a
construction manager and HR Pro you name
it whatever across industries software
advice will help you save time and to
help you make a more informed decision
if you're an entrepreneur or you work
solo software advice is a great way to
get an expert opinion even without the
resources of a big company use these
tools at your fingertips they are really
helpful experts are ready to be on call
your uncle go-to team and help you
figure out business software in minutes
for free why wouldn't you do it and the
software struggles today go to software
advice.com slash knowles K&O wles to get
started that's software advice.com slash
knowles kano wles connect with an
advisor for free it's free come on
people I'm don't say I never did nothing
for you come on software advice comm
slash Knowles it's really helpful when
I've when I've worked with these small
businesses
even waste so much time and a lot of
money trying to figure out the right
software okay let's have our
conversation let's have our conversation
first about the conversation there's so
many conversations today this is a real
one now the conversation is coming up
with the big boss himself mr. ben
shapiro 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 Pacific
you know how to do it only daily wire
subscribers can ask the questions Ben
will answer the questions in real time
just go to that page on The Daily wire
website type in your question they will
be answered by the lovely Alicia Kraus
in the order that they come in be sure
to tune in for it everybody can watch
but only subscribers can ask questions
many are called but few are chosen
ask Ben every question you've ever
wanted to know Ben what does your wife
do for a living I had people have I've
been trying I've known Ben for years at
this point he's never actually told me
so you can ask that question yourself
watch the conversation 5:30 p.m. Eastern
2:30 Pacific and become a subscriber
that way you can talk to Ben yourself
you know it's weird though because I'm a
subscriber and but Ben won't talk to me
maybe I maybe I've got to take that up
with HR or something like that with my
subscription manager at The Daily wire
ok so I want to talk I want to have a
conversation with you about national
conversations that's the euphemism that
Democrats and lefties are always using
whenever they just want to shove
something down your throat so they say
we need a national conversation for it
you know even people on the right have
picked up this kind of language let's
take a look at just a quick little
overview of all of the national
conversations we are we're having a
national conversation about it how to
help drive a national conversation
ignited a national conversation about
mental health trying to advance the
cause of the national conversation about
such things as immigration national
conversation around sexual harassment
behind this national conversation on
transgender rights you know we must have
a national conversation on raise Donald
Trump's vulgar remarks about women
started a national conversation about
sexual assault did it did it now mister
CBS anchor guy national conversation
means whatever Democrats want to talk
about Democrats talking to you about
them that's what at a national
verse Asians look at it Donald Trump if
for those of you who can't see it this
is the image on on CBS News Donald
Trump's lewd comments started a national
conversation on sexual assault and it
says hashtag not okay underneath Donald
Trump this is on CBS this is purportedly
a journalist outlet okay so Donald Trump
said some vulgar things in a private
conversation to Billy Bush little locker
room talk that started in a national
conversation but when Bill Clinton was
sexually harassing his interns and
actually raping people that didn't start
a national conversation right why didn't
it start a national conversation oh
because you people control the national
conversation or at least you used to
before the new media broke the
mainstream media's stranglehold on what
we're all talking about it now you've
got to see through this euphemism there
are so many of these lefty euphemisms we
hear about politically correct does a
lot of this right there are all these
little terms that we use that don't
really mean we say that they mean this
is one of them because it's not a
conversation I'll tell you this this
happened to me yesterday on Twitter some
comic book guy with a blue checkmark I
don't know what he does
he started tweeting all these vulgar and
mean things at me because I was
suggesting that we shouldn't have
completely open borders and we should
try to stop illegal immigration because
it hurts both the United States and the
illegal aliens themselves and he started
tweeting all these awful things and then
I say okay goodbye have a nice day
goodbye stop no right and they're just
yelling invective and accusations he
called all Trump supporters racists and
evil and wicked and terrible a lot of
other blue checkmarks jumped in on the
thread and that's what they want in a
conversation they want to slander people
libel people say you're awful and you're
hateful and I use a lot of profanity and
then that's it and then leave and you
see this a lot even on Twitter another
person who responded they said they said
something mean and I said okay thanks
bye bye bye Felicia
that's another lefty kind of meme they
say bye Felicia goodbye I'm not
listening to you I'm not talking to you
anymore this even goes all the way up to
serious elected Democrats Hillary
Clinton and the chief Lea Wafaa
Elizabeth
Warren herself Foca haunt us they both
tweeted to Donald Trump delete your
account so Hillary Clinton tweeted she
said delete your account when he said
something who knows and then Elizabeth
Warren the same thing seriously delete
your account delete it right that's not
a conversation that's the opposite of a
conversation they're actually things
shut up when the left calls for a
national conversation they are telling
you conservative - shut up and listen to
us it is you know Jay I did a Prager you
video on this on how the left
manipulates language to mean the
opposite of what it is like a social
justice which - when the left says it it
means not justice you know and so the
that's what they do
with the conversation it means not a
conversation the opposite of a national
conversation then that kid from the the
school that had that awful shooting in
Florida David Hawk who immediately after
the shooting became a CNN celebrity was
on CNN all of the time he recently
tweeted out if we get these advertisers
pulled maybe Laura Ingraham will have to
become a camp counselor and learn how
wrong she is and this just came out
today
David hog and some of the other
activists from that County in Florida
have been trying to get Laura Ingraham
kicked off the air for a long time
why because they disagree with her
opinion that's not a national
conversation is it that's trying to shut
up the other side that is and you see
this on campuses all the time people
physically assaulting speakers at
campuses ben shapiro goes to berkeley
cost $600,000 to secure the city in the
campus against a five-foot-nine Orthodox
Jewish guy who's relatively mild
mannered you know I there was a free
speech conference at Yale and as the
students were walking into the
conference there were protesters
spitting on them literally spitting on
they say how dare you want to speak too
you know so it it's all the opposite
here why is it why is that the national
conversation for Democrats it's because
they don't understand what you're saying
you can tell this in all conversation I
reference Twitter because it's where
people have these very fast
of conversations all the time and
sometimes there are a lot of followers
so these conversations are magnified and
we can watch them but Twitter is not an
aberration Twitter is the natural
conclusion of conversation and if
people's character so it is
conversations that's really that are
really happening but they say that
character is what you do when you think
nobody's looking I think a lot of these
people wouldn't come up and look you in
the face and say you're an evil vicious
Nazi because they're probably afraid of
you you're gonna you know they don't
have the courage to do that they don't
have the guts but from behind their
keyboards from behind their screens
they'll say whatever they want
you know character is what you do when
nobody is looking at you in the room
that you know a lot of people have
courage there and so it's this natural
conclusion but who would ever talk to
somebody that way I you know when you
look at two people having a conversation
in real life on television on a debate
stage or on Twitter the person who's
calm and who just sort of responds with
citing certain facts or certain logical
arguments that guy probably knows what
he's talking about and the person who's
screaming and ripping his hair out and
yelling invective and all that maybe
that guy doesn't know exactly what he's
talking about it is actually a pretty
good mirror for conversation and usually
the louder people are the less they know
the more they're screaming the more
profanity they use the less confident
they are of their opinion because they
have to juice it up with all these sort
of little add-ons so you know listen
I've invited a lot of Democrats on this
show I've invited a ton of lefties
wackos radicals Democrats the only one
really who's come on is Tom Arnold so
you know Tom Arnold did come off a
little eccentric on the show but and a
lot of people are attacking him for that
but I got to say at least he came on all
these Democrats going for a national
conversation they'll never come on the
show they won't do it why because
they're not confident of their views
they don't know what they're talking
about and when you don't know what
you're talking about you get very angry
and there was that wonderful study from
Jonathan Hite that came out a number of
years ago which showed that the
Conservatives broadly understand the
left much much better than the left
understands conservatives and if you
don't understand conservatives if you're
a lefty
and you don't understand why someone
would want to enforce our own
immigration laws or why we don't want
perfectly open borders where people can
flood unvetted into the United States if
you don't understand that then the
person who is offering those opinions
can be one of two things
stupid or evil right if you're a
progressive you have an idea of progress
you have a utopia at the end of the line
then if you're gonna stand in the way of
progress which is so clear you can
either be stupid or evil and when they
look at well-spoken conservatives they
say oh you have to be evil and when they
look at inarticulate conservatives they
say you have to be stupid but the answer
of course is neither I don't think that
the left is stupid or evil I'll tell you
what I think they are before we do that
let's talk about expressvpn this is so
important this is so so important you
are being tracked you are being spied on
right now by mobile carriers by Internet
service providers by possibly hackers
who have total access to your web
history and Internet data and if I know
anything about my audience it's that
they look at some pretty weird stuff on
the internet either that's gonna be my
bet I'm not exactly a gambling man you
know you go sometimes late at night you
go down into the basement you open up
that secret tab on the browser and then
you type in D a i ly wire.com daily
wiring you story you hope no one's
looking or anything yeah well you don't
want people to know about that come on
expressvpn can really help it encrypts
your traffic and sensitive data while
masking your IP address it conceals your
online activity from everybody look it's
all in the news you've been getting all
those emails and new privacy policy new
privacy new privacy yeah right all Mark
Zuckerberg is going before Congress
these big tech giants who have all of
your data that we've just given to them
for some reason they've all been
testifying because they know this is a
big deal don't let them track you
Comcast Verizon Time Warner the list
goes on and on and on with expressvpn my
internet data is encrypted with my IP
address hidden it's less than seven
bucks a month it's rated the number one
VPN service by TechRadar dozens of other
expert reviewers seriously guys seven
bucks a month you do not want your
personal data out there you don't
people spying on you especially if you
use public Wi-Fi at the coffee shop at
the airport or whatever do not do it it
is the best seven bucks you're gonna
spend make sure you'd be crazy to go on
unsecured Wi-Fi these days
take back your in that privacy today
find out how you can get three months
for free don't say I never did nothing
for you go to expressvpn comm slash
cough fa CoV Fe Fe that is e XP or e SS
V P n com / cough fa Co V Fe Fe I hope
you're good at spelling that is three
months free with a one-year package
every day you use the internet with
expressvpn you're putting sensitive
information I'm sorry every day using it
without expressvpn you're putting your
sensitive information at risk when you
use Express VPN you'll be protecting
your data and that is really really
valuable do not put it off do it right
now expressvpn comm slash cough fa to
learn more so I don't think that lefties
and Democrats and all the ones who are
yelling invectives and everything
against us I don't think that they're
stupid or evil broadly speaking I just
think they're ignorant they're ignorant
of these things when they come out you
know 2014-2015 Barack Obama was doing
exactly the same thing that everyone is
hysterical for Donald Trump doing right
now on immigration miners were being
detained they're being detained by the
US government in some cases they were
being separated from their families in
some cases they were being held in
custody with their families which the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals ruled is
illegal so then they had to be pulled
away from their families this is the New
York Times reporting on this 2014-2015
judge G also found that migrant children
had been held in widespread deplorable
conditions I got to tell you it if for
those of you who don't believe in a
divine hand and everything
look at that adjective they're
deplorable conditions as the left is
losing its mind over a policy that
Donald Trump is basically just
continuing and in some ways finally
enforcing the word that the New York
Times used to describe and this judge
used to describe the Obama
administration years ago is deplorable
let's do good in border patrol
stations after they were first caught
and she said the authorities had wholly
failed to provide the safe and sanitary
conditions required for children even in
temporary cells so by the way all the
stories that are coming out these
opportunistic Democrat politicians are
now flooding down to these centers where
the children are being held by HHS not
by u.s. marshals but by HHS and they're
flooding down there to interview them
and get a good photo op or whatever but
they're all admitting the conditions are
actually pretty nice they have nice
murals on the walls and they're being
cared for very nicely it's not like
they're in a gulag or something or in
prison except when Barack Obama was
doing kids actually were being held in
deplorable conditions much worse
conditions than they're being held in
under the Trump administration but no
one's really talking about that are they
we'll get to why in a little bit the New
York Times goes on quote initially
homeland security officials said they
were detaining the families to send a
message to others in Central America to
deter them from coming to the United
States illegally there it is there it is
the main argument against President
Trump enforcing immigration laws that
were passed years ago actually just
enforcing them the main argument they're
saying is he is doing this to be mean
he's doing this to send a deterrent to
people who would cross the border he
wants to be so awful and terrible and
mean and nasty that people won't keep
coming across the border homeland
security officials and under Barack
Obama admitted that they were doing this
very thing do you see that trending on
Twitter right now is that trending in
the national conversation or the
networks the television networks that
are spending an absurd amount of time
covering the Trump administration's
alleged misdeeds here are they talking
about those deplorable conditions and
those deterrence that the Obama
administration were putting into place
of course not
that gets to the nature of the national
conversation we'll get to that in a
second the news coverage over the over
six days in June we're talking about six
days of coverage how long do you think
they spent covering this issue what
would you say maybe they do a couple
minutes a night so yeah there's this law
in the books and now the Trump
administration is enforcing it I know
why this is news that the federal
government is enforcing its own laws but
right 176 minutes of emotional segments
by emotional segments I mean little
babies crying children crying and there
yeah where's mommy they're cry right a
hundred seventy six minutes of this
because the federal government is
enforcing the law because Donald Trump
is doing what Barack Obama did now do
you think do you think that they were
covering this under Barack Obama how
long do you bet they spent so a hundred
seventy six minutes under Donald Trump
how long do you think they spent under
Barack Obama when he was doing exactly
the same thing well you do you the
number is six minutes it's six minutes
and 29 seconds
176 minutes under donald trump 6 minutes
and 29 seconds under barack obama for
doing the exact same thing except in the
case of barack obama the conditions that
the children were being held in were
much worse that's the difference CBS
alone we saw that the ridiculous
propaganda clip in the national
conversation from CBS CBS alone has
spent 73 minutes
in six days this month talking about the
awful horrific unspeakable crime of the
federal government enforcing its own
laws and following what the Ninth
Circuit judges told us we had to do
that's the difference they're doing this
and they're pretending that it's
conversation this isn't a congress a it
were conversation then the network's
would be airing the same number of
segments when barack obama did it if
this were a conversation they wouldn't
be these emotionally manipulative clips
of little babies crying they would have
people on discussing whether or not we
should enforce the law whether or not we
should repeal the law having a sane
conversation a conversation is basically
impossible with the left these days
because we don't speak the same language
and and I don't think there's equal
share of blame to go around it is the
left which is abandoned language they
don't know what we're talking about it
is ignorant and unfortunately there are
some people on the right here who are
falling for it and this is the squishes
the squishes on the right like gay like
yeah but Bush keep they keep falling for
this sort of thing
so what did jeb say he came out he said
we need to give these dreamers a path to
citizenship and it's heartless what's
Donald Trump is doing
it's heartless please new york times
like me like why don't you like me new
york times that's what a yet Bush is
coming out and saying it they're falling
for it Laura Bush published that awful
op-ed that terrible slander against
Republicans and against the Trump
administration yesterday saying that if
you you're basically a bad person if you
think we should enforce immigration law
that was signed into law under her
husband she failed to mention that in
the in the op-ed that she wrote didn't
she a Donald Trump knows better than
this we're very lucky that the guy is in
office right now because lesser weaker
politicians this would have broken them
the call you hate little children you
hate little babies forget that it's all
nonsense forget that it's all media
manipulation this would have broken
other presidents it was I'm sorry we'll
stop it my bad Mayor colpa Mia culpa mea
Maxima culpa not Donald Trump he doubles
down he he responds he says crime in
Germany up ten percent plus since
migrants were accepted and this is not
being reported and America be smart now
that seems like a zag why is he talking
about crime in Germany you strive a
crime in Germany to put an image to what
this could mean for the United States we
see what's happening in Germany we know
that the the country is being flooded
with aliens and refugees quote-unquote
who are causing a lot of terror attacks
and he says if you if you don't have
borders you don't have a country in the
past four years a thousand people in
Germany have been killed and injured by
refugees thousand people in four years
by refugees he's drawing that image for
you and he kept on swinging here's
President Trump Democrats love open
borders let the whole world come in let
the whole world ms-13 gang members from
all over the place come on in we have
open borders and they view that possibly
intelligently except that it's
destroying our country they view that as
potential voters
day they're gonna vote for Democrats
because they can't win on their policies
which are horrible they found that out
in the last presidential election
[Applause]
[Laughter]
in fact their only policy was that
Donald Trump is a bad guy he's a bad
person vote against Trump and they said
it so many there's hundreds of millions
of dollars of negative ads nobody's ever
been hit like that I used to go home
I started disliking myself I said man am
i that bad that's that's exactly right
that's all they've got there but you're
bad you're bad and you say but what
about this they say uh your bed I
actually have a national conversation in
this country I think this is what it
would look like I'm not asking you I'm
telling you who is on every dollar of it
yes what's the guy's name on second base
I am NOT asking you who's on second son
first I don't know he's on third we're
not talking about him Abbott and
Costello
that is the national conversation that
is happening right now between
Republicans and Democrats between the
right and the left the Republicans and
Democrats are Bud Abbott the tall guy
the straight man or I'm sorry the
Republicans are Bud Abbott the tall guy
the straight man the Democrats are Lou
Costello this sort of shorter pudgy or
unkempt one wearing the silly hat that
business that is
I think I just described the Democrat
Party perfectly that is the national
conversation because an often overlooked
aspect of who's on first maybe the most
famous comedy routine in history is that
the straight man but Abbott understands
exactly what's going on he can tell it's
not it isn't that complicated the reason
that this is funny is because we
understand what's going on because it
isn't that complicated and then Lou
Costello who's the comic guy who just
can't understand anything he is the
Democrat he he can't figure out that who
is on first what is on second I don't
know is on third he can't figure out and
that's what's so funny about it
so you know you've got Bud Abbott there
the Republicans straight man who just
says look I'll tell you the names of
everybody on the team I won't get
confused who's on second what's on who's
on first what's on second I was on third
and then Lou Costello comes and he says
wait who was on who's on second what's
on first I don't know who was right he
can't get it that's what's happening in
the United States we we did that
interview with Tom Arnold Tom said you
know Trump is a Russian asset I said
explain how and he couldn't explain how
because it was just there was a simple
question that could have led but he
couldn't explain how because they're the
Democrats just have this list of talking
points I don't mean to pick on Tom
everyone is spewing this on that side of
the aisle all they have are these
shallow talking points they can't follow
a logical argument they are not
interested in following a logical
argument then getting back to who's on
first
you see Bud Abbott he stays basically
calm he says look this is what it is
naturally naturally absolutely do to do
to do and Lou Costello he's getting
angrier and angrier why I who I'm gonna
zing zing right and that is the
Democrats right now they're ripping
their O'Hara and they're also wearing
stupid hats just like Lou Costello
they're going out there and wearing
those silly hats this isn't black and
white so I can't tell if Lou Costello's
had is pink or not but that is what the
Democrats are doing right now you can't
have a national national conversation
with that they they aren't up to the
level of discourse they aren't
sufficiently able to use language and to
process ideas
to be able to communicate that somebody
on Twitter tweeted out at me some lefty
said f you and F this and F and doo
dodoo dodoo dodoo and some other blue
checkmark guy I don't know I think he's
a writer he said I couldn't have said it
better
I couldn't have said it better myself I
know I said I know you couldn't have
said it better that's the sad part about
our culture it's you're a professional
writer and you couldn't say it better
David McCullough's says to write well is
to think clearly that's why it's so hard
when you see these wacko lefties on
Twitter using profanity and slurs and
calling you all sorts of bad things it's
because they aren't thinking clearly
but if they're not thinking clearly if
they're not willing to use their
cognitive faculties you cannot have a
conversation that is just not possible
and so at least some people like
President Trump they see this for what
it is the the squishy people they look
they see the Democrats get really angry
they say oh we should take them
seriously we should try to seriously
engage with your temper tantrums and
with your invective and your slurs we
should seriously and Donald Trump says
now I'm not going to reward you for
acting like a little child I wouldn't
have a heightened discourse with a
little toddler they're not capable of
that they're all emotion and angry and
and not able to think clearly so I'm
just gonna punch right back I'm gonna
hit you right back and he keeps doing
that he's not taking the democrat
premises and we shouldn't either they're
not interested in a national
conversation they're interested in
entrapment in college just using a
cudgel and banging you on the head
that's what they want like Lou Costello
starts to get angry with the bat right
because I'm gonna get you but then no
don't let them do it don't let them do
it because that's what they want here's
another great example of this is the UN
Human Rights Council it was just
announced today that we're pulling out
of the UN Human Rights Council and this
was another there's a headline the left
they said all my gosh Donald Trump is
pulling out of the UN Human Rights
Council
oh no no who's on the human UN Human
Rights Council let's just see if I can
remember a few uh Cuba Cuba's on it
Venezuela people starving in the street
eating rats Venezuela's on the Human
Rights Saudi Arabia is on the Human
Rights Council
yeah that's they finally let women drive
this year they're they're finally
considering letting women drive China
which had a national policy for decades
of massive bortion
of children those are the estimates have
been a slave state since the Communists
Communists took power so that's the
Human Rights Council Donald Trump saw
through that he doesn't get tricked by
those those claims those premises says
nope here's Rhee
it's really and this is actually good
news for the culture we're gonna have to
sign off but before we do that I do want
to point out this is a good thing this
is the last last gasps of a sick culture
the tide is turning the left has nothing
left worldwide
Italy has just elected a government that
wants to deal with this craziness with
the craziness the illogic of open
borders for instance and it's actually
sort of what we would call bipartisan
there's this right-wing party the the
movimento chic wait I'm sorry the the
leg a party and then this sort of
left-wing party the movimento Cinque CLA
and they've formed this coalition
government Matteo salvini is the
interior minister there and he turned
away a ship of so-called refugees the MS
Aquarius and these aren't refugees who
were just off the coast of Calabria and
they pulled him on shore these boats
would go and proud the Libyan Coast and
find anybody who was you know sitting in
a tube drinking a daiquiri probably not
exactly doing that but who were very
close to the Libyan Coast and picked
them up and bring them to Europe and
they get to stay in Europe and Italy has
to deal with all of that it doesn't make
any sense there were 1.2 6 billion
people in Africa is Italy going to
absorb over a billion people I don't
think so by the way this this got shock
and indignation all around Europe
Germany was horrified France macron was
horrified oh no this is terrible what
could happen meanwhile by the way as
Angela Merkel is so shocked and
horrified by this the German Interior
Minister Horst C Hoffer was the head of
Bavaria's Christian Union so a Christian
social Union actually called up salvini
and congratulated him he said oh thank
you for having common sense and finally
turning this away Sylvania said to
Macaroni said oh if you're so upset
about this how about you take all these
refugees for years and years and years
macron hasn't responded yet and 60% of
Italians support this policy 60 because
there is a turning not just in the
United States but worldwide it's working
how bad in the United States Trump's
popularity mainstream media breathlessly
reporting poor little kids that being
ripped out making up total fake news
with regard to the Obama administration
Trump's popularity hits an all-time high
45% amidst all of this all-time high
45% there's a top
mcwrap candidate running for Congress in
West Virginia's name's Richard Ojeda he
he's campaigning on this line I voted
for Trump that's that's one of his
campaign lines top Democrat prospect
this is saying I voted for Trump please
vote for me really really good news for
the culture we've got even more good
news for the culture we got to talk
about Chris Pratt we got to talk about
we've got to get our daily world cup
update and we've got to talk about the
Rosenbergs America executing Soviet
spies back when we had a spine but I've
got a second byte of Facebook in YouTube
I'm sorry folks but yeah it's all right
you'll get to come back later and see
the conversation with the big boss ben
shapiro that's coming up soon if you
subscribe you get me you get the end
reclaim ensure you get to ben shapiro
show $10 a month $100 for annual
membership none of that matters this is
what matters because the mainstream meet
they are losing their minds they are Lou
Costello why running all this end oh wow
wow that tastes like 45% approval
ratings doesn't that really does I go to
daily wire.com we'll be right back
you didn't watch the MTV Movie Awards
last night I'm shocked if you missed it
here's all you need to see from it
this being the Generation Award I'm
gonna I'm gonna cut to the chase and I'm
gonna speak to you the next generation
okay I accept the responsibility as your
elder so listen up you have a soul be
careful with it God is real God loves
you God wants the best for you
believe that I do learn to pray it's
easy and it's so good for your soul
and finally number nine nobody is
perfect people are gonna tell you you're
perfect just the way you are you're not
you are imperfect you always will be but
there is a powerful force that designed
you that way
and if you're willing to accept that you
will have grace and grace is a gift and
like the freedom that we enjoy in this
country that grace was paid for with
somebody else's blood do not forget it
don't take it for granted
god bless you please get home safely
thank you preach preach Christmas
Christmas for Governor of California I
mean what a wonderful speech from Chris
Pratt a movie star and we're finally
hearing that and you heard by the way
when he said God exists there's a cheer
there was a huge amount of applause in
the audience this is I really think
we're turning a corner here I really
think that the more they turn up this
hysteria it's because they're losing the
left is losing after so long they aren't
making and so thank goodness we have
political leaders who are willing to
stand firm and say no we're not gonna
have open borders we're not going I'm
know you failed your policy failed your
policy is morally idiotic we are going
to protect our country and stand firm
against that it doesn't matter it's just
like a little they're just bubbling all
their all their anger but it's cuz
they're losing and then on the culture
you get guys like Chris Pratt coming up
you've got the Generation Award right he
comes up and he says all right here's my
advice kiddos God is real you have a
soul and protect it and you better pray
and you're not perfect and when people
try to affirm you because that was
clearly a shot at this self empowerment
self-esteem movement daily affirmation
kind of culture that we're in now where
they say you're perfect don't change
you're wonderful the way you are Chris
Pratt says no you're not you're
obviously imperfect and grace abounds
because you're imperfect beautiful
beautiful stuff and really gives you
hope for the culture something else
gives me hope for the culture too this
is really important so I don't know if
you've been following this we've we've
mentioned soccer on the show in the last
couple days you probably haven't seen it
we haven't made a big deal about it but
we have brought up the World Cup a
little bit and so all the girls in the
office all the girls in the office and
Paul Bois are pretending to like soccer
right now and it's very it's very
frustrating and somewhat amusing because
nobody can name any soccer players ever
but they're like kind of hot or
something I don't know right and it's
very fashionable to like soccer now so
you might have seen me Alicia and I were
sniping at each other on Twitter this
morning and she sent me an article she
said see this is from deadline and the
headline from deadline is Fox sports
scores viewers
ship record with Mexico's World Cup win
and Brazil tie with Swiss and I got very
upset when I saw I got very depressed I
thought other cultures over doesn't
matter about Chris Pratt doesn't matter
that we're closing up our border it's
not that's it's over right but then I
looked a little more closely at
viewership record Fox Sports that a
World Cup game is the biggest audience
they ever drew I realized they left a
couple words out of that they left out a
soccer game record so they must be in
brackets Fox sports scores viewership
soccer game record with Mexico's blah
blah blah so the the game had four and a
half million viewers to put that into
context Super Bowl 44 had a hundred
fourteen point four million viewers so
about three point what 93.9% of the
viewership of the Super Bowl watched
this record-setting World Cup game 25
times more than 25 times as many people
as watched that record-setting World Cup
game watched Super Bowl 44 the Oscars
2018 there was an all-time low in
ratings all-time low in viewership still
got over 26 million people so it the
worst lowest rated Oscars ever got six
times as many viewers as the
record-setting World Cup game the
average NFL game gets fourteen point
nine million viewers that is the average
world average NFL game the lowest rated
of last season was about 8 million a
little over like 8.1 million and the
highest was almost 26 million compared
to four-and-a-half million for the
record-setting World Cup game oh thank
goodness oh thank goodness but it this
does show you something by the way the
deadline headline which we're seeing in
a lot of places you know record-setting
viewership is way way up it's just
propaganda there is a concerted effort
among the media to get Americans to like
soccer and they're not even hiding it
they write articles all the time that
say you should like soccer here's why
you should watch soccer I talked about
this on the Andrew Clavin show the other
day but it's fake news thank goodness
though it gives me hope for the culture
as I lose half of my audience
finally we only have a few minutes left
but I do want to wrap up on this day in
history because on this day in history
the United States government fried a
couple of Soviet spies who are
actually responsible for killing
American soldiers I speak of course of
Julius and Ethel Rosenberg who were
executed by the government on this day
in history in 1953 this is an important
case not really because of the
Rosenbergs but because of what it means
for the left in America and our national
conversation as we always call it so
Julius was he worked in the Army Signal
Corps engineering laboratory and he was
you know working around this laboratory
on important projects right at a time
when the United States is developing
atomic bombs and fighting major Wars and
Trott you know really trying to get an
edge on our opponents but not only in
the Axis powers but also after our
alliance with Russia and he was fired
when it was discovered that he was a
member of the Communist Party so for
years his co-defendant Morton Sobell
said that he was innocent
the Rosenbergs children said the parents
were innocent they were innocent they
talked for decades and the American Left
defended them for decades and decades
and decades until 2008 when old Morty
Sobell admitted they were all guilty
they were all spies they were spies for
the Soviet Union the left insisted for a
whole half-century their martyrs there
were martyrs from the government which
is repressive and trying to put down
dissent and was trying to shut up
left-wing voices and they unjustly
killed these innocent people with
trumped-up charges
nope turns out that was all fake and I
bet a lot of you in high school learned
that the Rosenbergs were killed unjustly
that it was a setup that they there's no
evidence that they were that they were
really spies this still persists in 2008
their co-conspirator admitted we tried
to pass on nuclear technology to the
Soviets nuclear secrets and they did
pass on other secrets in 2015 the New
York City Council under Bolshevik Mayor
Bill DeBlasio honored Ethel Rosenberg
for her great bravery we know for a fact
that she passed on secrets to the
Soviets we know that Ethel by the way
according to many historians hid money
she hid espionage paraphernalia for her
husband
she acted as an intermediary between the
Soviets and her husband she was present
at many meetings we know all of this and
yet there was a study by the historian
Larry Schweikart who's at the University
of Dayton that showed that a hue Ament
very few textbooks admit that the
Rosenbergs are guilty the vast majority
of textbooks say oh they were innocent
or this is another trick because they
say oh it's controversial it was a
controversial decision
you hear this Oh Donald Trump's policy
at the border is controversial why is it
controversial it was it was passed by
Democrats have signed into law two
administrations ago it was enforced at
various times what's controversial it's
like the opposite of controversial right
but they use that to to cast down the
the Columbia professor Eric Foner said
until very recently he said they were
prosecuted the Rosenbergs out of a
determined effort to root out dissent to
shatter careers and suppress civil
liberties no they were just commie spies
they were just communist spies that the
Rosenbergs tried to give the soviets
top-secret information from the
Manhattan Project they did hand over top
military data on sonar and radar that
information led directly to the Russians
shooting down u.s. planes in the Korean
Conflict in the Vietnam War though it
led directly to that Rosenberg's have
blood on their hands this they did the
same thing with Alger Hiss by the way
the American left Alger Hiss was a State
Department official he helped start the
UN and he was accused of being a
communist spy he was accused by
Whittaker Chambers another ex communist
party member and who admitted to spying
himself and nobody believed Chambers
everybody defended his how dare you how
dare you say this really only Richard
Nixon came out and said I believe
chambers I think he is a dirty rotten
commie and it finally it turned out that
this was a communist and they never
forgave Nixon for that that's why they
left dogged him his entire career so the
takeaway here is do not let the left get
to you when we have our national
conversations and they call you all
manner of evil and say terrible things
about you slander from these people as a
badge of honor it means you're doing
something right because it means that
you're on to something it means that you
know you're maybe you're getting a
little too close for comfort and they
will slander you and
to destroy you but that's the point when
the left is saying nice things about you
you're probably doing something wrong
look at Jeb Bush right now look at mrs.
Bush right now that's not the place
where you want to be there are always
those you know the Republican who
Democrats who the left really likes that
the Republican who the New York Times
really likes that guy is usually doing
something wrong right that's the
evidence that you're doing something
wrong don't be that guy don't let the
left get to you and persevere in our
national conversation knowing that
nobody wants to have a conversation with
you on the Left they are trying to hit
you
don't be naive we're supposed to be wise
as serpents and innocent as doves those
squishy Republicans want to be wisest of
an innocent as serpents don't do it
folks keep keep your eyes peeled and and
look at reality square in the face
because we are winning the culture it's
turning in our direction okay that's the
show I will see you tomorrow we got a
lot of cool stuff coming up this week
make sure to get your mailbag questions
and tune in for the conversation later
on today in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the micromoles show I'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you